bye
it turns its attention at first to its
purity that is its abstract form but
since reason qua observer apprehends the
object which moves among its own
distinct movement moments as an inert
being its laws of thought become
connections of one constant moment to
another constant moment
but the content of these laws being only
moments these run together into the
single unit of self-consciousness
this new object similarly taken as an
inert being is the single contingent
self-consciousness
observation stands therefore within what
it imagines to be spirit and within the
contingent relation of conscious reality
to a reality that is not conscious
spirit alone is in its own self the
necessity of this relation
observation therefore looks more closely
at this object and compares its reality
which wills and acts with its reality
which ponders and is reflected into
itself a reality which is itself
objective this outer aspect although a
language of the individual which he
possesses within himself is at the same
time cross sign
something indifferent to the content it
is supposed to denote just as that which
posits for itself the sign is
indifferent to it
here in paragraph 242 hegel is
sketching out for us what it is that
observing reason has been observing
and where it is it is going he's also in
the paragraph that's going to follow
this
still
engaged in the critique of phrenology
giving it its own
place and showing where it's falling
apart and so this is sort of lead up
into that he starts out by talking about
the laws of thought and then moves to
single contingent self-consciousness
then talks about the relationship
between
different aspects you might say or sides
of conscious reality
self-consciousness and then he ends up
talking about the sign and and you
remember for hegel signed zeikan
is always going to be arbitrary he's not
a semiologist in the sense that you know
later people who are coming along
are where they see that signs are
motivated or they reveal more to us or
anything like that when hegel talks
about a sign
he really does think that the
relationship between signifier and
signified or with sign and and and
reference or whatever you want to call
it is is highly contingent it's it's you
know conventional it can be whatever you
want it to be so just keep that in in
the back your mind now
uh let's take up the text itself
he says um
it turns its attention what what's it
it's reason who is now trying to make
sense of things right and and he's going
to sketch out for us how it's getting
things wrong at first he says it turns
its attention first to its purity that
is its abstract form
but since reason qua observer apprehends
the object which moves among its own
distinct moments as an inert being
its laws of thought remember back in in
the section previous to this one
reason was attempting to produce laws of
thought logical and psychological
laws that would apply to human beings
across the board we saw that there were
some problems with that hegel is not
interested in those problems problems
essentially of freedom and agency at
this point an interpretation
he's interested in something different
he says well those laws of thought are
just connecting together
a bunch of
moments
and what does he mean by that well you
know a human life
and the thoughts that we have they are
occurring
you know through time right
and so what unifies those what connects
them together we can say well laws of
thought do but for who
for what
this is where we have a transition to
self-consciousness
and he talks about a single
contingent
self-consciousness or we we might just
as well talk about a whole bevy of
single contingent self-consciousnesses
because this could be any person this
could be any self-consciousness this
could be whatever it is
whoever it is rather that we want it to
be
so he goes on and he says
these laws of thought become connections
of one constant moment to another
constant moment but the content of these
laws being only moments these run
together into the single unit of
self-consciousness
this new object so this is an advance
this observing reason
has found something new for itself in
the process
this new object similarly taken as an
inert being
is the single contingent
self-consciousness that was a problem
right
the single contingent self-consciousness
was counter-posed to the laws of thought
and that's why in the transition from
the previous section of this section we
said okay
i get it the single cell contingent
self-consciousness that matters let's
look at him or her or it or whatever
of course when we do that we're also
saying let me look at me
or you
if we're doing phenomenology right
because i'm a single self i'm a single
contingent self-consciousness so are you
so is hegel
maybe
world historically perhaps not right
but you get the idea
so he he goes on and he says
observation stands within what it
imagines to be spirit notice that it's
imagining it to be spirit it's not hegel
is not saying this actually is what
spirit is
observation is getting this somewhat
wrong
he says within the contingent relation
of the other conscious reality to a
reality that is not conscious so
self-consciousness involves a
relationship between
consciousness conscious reality which is
it right
and a reality that is not conscious it's
it's other
the other of perception the other of
force and the understanding the other of
the the other person being treated
merely as an object for example in the
master slave dialectic um
the reversal of that that happened in
the unhappy consciousness where
one made oneself as talked about in the
next paragraph into
something that's supposed to be not
conscious that's just in itself and then
it gets displaced the agency the the the
you know spirituality gets displaced to
this beyond which is really one oneself
so this conscious reality
what happens when observation looks at
it more closely
well it splits up into two parts here's
something really interesting happens
hegel says observation looks more
closely at this object and compares its
reality
it's reality which
wills
right and
acts
right that's
uh that's that's the the verb there to
do to act right
it compares that against the other part
which is pondering
which is reflected
um reflected into itself the he compares
the reality which wills and acts which
with its reality which ponders and is
reflected into itself a reality as hegel
says which is itself objective
so this seems to be
where we've got the reflexivity of
self-consciousness right because
what is it pondering or reflecting on
well what it does
now notice what hegel does at this point
though
we would be tempted to say okay well
that's the inner that's the outer
you know this is where spirit is
probably going to be remember hegel has
consistently told us over and over and
over again
where is spirit where is reality where
where's the individual
it's in what you do
there's a you know affirmation of the
practical here
you are what you choose and what you do
even more than what you happen to think
or in this case
why is he talking about signs here
because this is what you say about
yourself
the pondering is the is the you talking
about what your actions mean what your
choices mean
so he goes on and he says
this outer aspect
although a language of the individual
which he possesses within himself
so it's outer and it's inner this outer
aspect
of a language
of the individual he possesses within
itself is at the same time qua sign
qua sign
something
indifferent to the content it is
supposed to denote what is the content
this stuff over here what what the
person is willing
isn't that interesting
this is a
classic hegelian reversal here
it's indifferent to the content it's
supposed to denote just as that which
posits for itself the sign is
indifferent to it
so
what we've got here is a
progression of reason
that is you might say slowly losing
sight of its object
this is going to happen even more
in the paragraph to come
for this reason observation finally goes
back again from this inconstant language
to the fixed being and declares in
accordance with its notion that
externality is the outer and immediate
reality of spirit not as an organ and
not as a language or a sign but as a
dead thing
what was ruled out by the very first
observation of inorganic nature that is
the idea that the notion ought to be
present in the form of a thing is
reinstated by this last form of
observation in such a way that it turns
the reality of spirit itself into a
thing or expressing it the other way
around gives to lifeless being the
significance of spirit
observation has here reached the point
where it openly declares what our notion
of it was that is that the certainty of
reason seeks its own self as an
objective reality
of course the intention here is not to
state that spirit which is represented
by a skull is a thing
there is not meant to be any materialism
as it is called in this idea rather
spirit must be something more and other
than these bones
but to say that spirit merely is means
nothing else that it is a thing
when being as such or thing hood is
predicated of spirit the true expression
of this is that spirit is therefore the
same kind of being that a bone is it
must therefore be regarded as extremely
important that the true expression has
been found for the bear statement about
spirit that it is
when in other respects it is said of
spirit that it is that it has being is a
thing a single separate reality this is
not intended to mean that it is
something we can see or take in our
hands or touch and so on but that is
what is
that is what is said and what really is
said is expressed by saying that the
being of spirit is a bone
we come now in paragraph 343
to hegel's very famous statement
that
spirit is a bone
it's where he actually says it as such
we've mentioned that a little bit
earlier in paragraphs leading up to this
but here is where he has that lapidary
saying
which has misled so many people hegel is
not saying spirit is a bone he's not
advocating that he's not celebrating
that as a great insight he is saying
that is one of the fundamental ways
in which observing reason or observation
goes astray this is a cul-de-sac that if
we stay in we will never get out of
this is not an advance it's only in
advance if we realize how wrong it is
and we move past it and so in this
paragraph he's really driving home to us
how mistaken this point of view is even
when it tries to build into itself a
certain kind of sophistication
so he starts out by talking about
observation or observing reason getting
away from the inconstant language that
we ended the last paragraph with and
wanting to shift to talking in terms of
a fixed being so what is that that fixed
being
he says that
it declares in accordance with its
notion that externality is the outer and
immediate reality of spirit
not as an organ not as a language or a
sign but as a dead thing
why is that important why does he bring
up this comparison not as a language
well at least a language has some sort
of it may be arbitrary but there's some
sort of signification there remember
back several paragraphs ago when we
talked about the skull ultimately
signifies nothing the only way you can
make it signify is when you put it next
to other skulls and you import some
meaning into it it's not a
sign
it's a dead thing it's not even an
organ
it says what was ruled out by the very
first observation of inorganic nature so
this is the sign
you know
this is where things are screwed up
what was ruled out from the very first
or observation of inter-organic nature
the idea that the notion ought to be
present in the form of a thing
is here being asserted as
the latest in in you know development
the the the fundamental achievement of
observe observation or observing reason
he says that what it does is this turns
the reality of spirit into a thing or
expressing it the other way around
gives to lifeless being the significance
of spirit
we saw that happen when talking about
well these bumps should should signify
they should have the significance of
things that are actually spiritual or
mental things that are distinctively
human
so he goes on and he says
observation has reached a point where
it's declaring what our notion of it was
that the certainty of reason
seeks its own self as an objective
reality hegel is
endorsing this reason is seeking its own
self
as an objective reality it's going to
continue to do so in the paragraphs yet
to come in this section and in the
section that follows the section that
follows right
what it's doing here where it's making a
mistake is saying well because it's
doing that
therefore
spirit can be understood as a being or
is going to amount to the same thing
as a thing
so he says the intention here's where
the the sophistication comes in the
intention is not to state that spirit
which is represented by a skull is a
thing there's not meant to be any
materialism at all as it's called in
this idea rather spirit must be
something more in other than these bones
but then you can say well
what what is it
besides these bones
and here's where the problem comes in
spirit is still being treated as just an
extra being on top of that being this is
why people who are struggling with you
know trying to make sense of how do you
get consciousness out of material things
are still struggling with this problem
today because they're looking for
something that would be an extra of the
same kind of being hegel talks about
this right here he says
to say that spirit merely is means
nothing else that it's a thing when
being as such or thing hood is
predicated of spirit
the true expression of this is what
that spirit
is the same kind of being that a bone is
so if you don't want to say spirit is a
bone
but you want to say that the bone
somehow
expresses spirit
then you wind up saying
that
spirit is something like a bone
a pseudo bone an uber bone or whatever
kind of bone you want right
but it's not spirit
you've lost sight of what spirit is in
in the process so that is a fundamental
problem
here that that he's he's expressing
so he says
it must therefore be regarded as
extremely important that the true
expression has been found for the bear
statement about spirit
that it is
right spirit is
spirit is what a spirit is a being
spirit is something in itself spirit is
something that observing reason can look
around and find and then be done with
if it does that it's not really grasping
spirit
because spirit is something
more and not just more in the sense of
adding more stuff on just a you know
bad infinity but but rather transcending
it
so he says
when in other respects instead of spirit
that it is that it has being is a thing
a single separate reality this is not
intended to mean it's something we can
see or take in our hands or touch but
that is what is said
hegel is is telling us here
you may disavow any sort of materialism
or reductionism in taking this sort of
stance
but that doesn't evade reductionism you
are still reducing spirit
to something
that is less than it and that's a
fundamental problem
so is there any way in which we can
address this this problem
it's not going to be by simply
reinstating this point of view
he says
what is really said
is is expressed by saying that the being
of spirit
is a bone
the being of spirit
now
you could say there's there's a way out
of this for the the person who's caught
in this trap
maybe they can say that the spirituality
of spirit is something different than
than the bone or the different than the
extra that we're putting in there but
that's not what the person is saying
that hegel is taking as the interlocutor
and even if they did say it so what then
they still have to explain
what that extra is don't they
and that's just not being provided here
so here we're seeing how how phrenology
is winding up in a fundamental
problematic that it can't get out of
now this result has a two-fold
significance one is its true meaning
insofar as it is a completion of the
outcome of the preceding
movement of self-consciousness
the unhappy self-consciousness renounced
its independence and struggle to make
its being for self into a thing
it thereby reverted from
self-consciousness to consciousness that
is to the consciousness for which the
object is something which merely is a
thing
but here what is a thing is
self-consciousness the thing is
therefore the unity of the i and being
the category
the object being determined thus for
consciousness the latter possesses
reason consciousness as well as
self-consciousness is in itself reason
but only that consciousness for which
the object is determined as the category
can be said to have reason
from this however we must still
distinguish the knowledge of what reason
is the category which is the immediate
unity of being and self must pass
through both forms and it is precisely
for consciousness qua observer that the
category presents itself in the form of
being
this consciousness in its result
enunciates as a proposition that of
which it is the unconscious certainty
the proposition that is implicit in the
notion of reason
this proposition is the infinite
judgment that the self is a thing a
judgment that suspends itself
through this result then the category is
further determined as being this
self-superseding antithesis the pure
category which is present for
consciousness in the form of being or
immediacy is the object as still
unmediated as merely given and
consciousness is equally unmediated in
its relation to it
the moment of that infinite judgment is
the transition of immediacy into
mediation or negativity the given object
is consequently determined as a negative
object consciousness however is
determined as a self-consciousness over
against it in other words the category
which in the course of observation has
run through the form of being is now
posited in the form of being for self
consciousness no longer aims to find
itself immediately but to produce itself
by its own activity it is itself the end
at which its action aims whereas in its
role of observer it was concerned only
with things
paragraph 344 is
let's say from the very start
a bit obscure
and i think that it's going to benefit
from some commentary and from charting
things out on the chalkboard a bit
i want to say to begin with that there
aren't any paragraphs in hegel that i
think are easy to
read and immediately grasp what he's
saying just on the first reading they
often require a lot of going back over
and thinking about what he's what he's
doing and that that's good that's the
way it ought to be if what he's doing
here is indeed a phenomenology of spirit
but there are times where you're
probably
left wondering should i skip this
paragraph or can i figure out what he's
talking about and so hopefully this will
help out a bit
um he starts out by by talking about the
unhappy consciousness and he talks about
it as the unhappy self-consciousness
which is correct because it's part of
the self-consciousness section right and
he says that this is the result of
things for the phrenology is
culminated in this so he says this is
the true meaning in so far as it's a
completion of the outcome of the
preceding moments movement of
self-consciousness
unhappy self-consciousness renounced its
independence
it struggled to make its being for self
into a thing so that that was sort of
what was going on
uh in these last several paragraphs that
we've been looking at you know if spirit
is a bone
then spirit is being turned into a thing
and so
that is similar to what was going on
with the unhappy consciousness in that
case it was you know projecting the
other
out into the void and finding it there
is god or something you know divine like
that
so he says that it reverted in doing so
there's a very important point from
self-consciousness to
consciousness to the consciousness for
which the object is something which
merely is a thing
now notice what happened in the process
so it projects
self-consciousness
agency out there to the divine to the
eternal
and in the process transforms itself
into just consciousness it's just there
to behold or to act in relation to that
but what ends up happening in the
process is self-consciousness gets
turned into a thing
and that's why it's the unhappy
consciousness because it doesn't have a
reconciliation
with itself by by engaging in this
gambit of projecting its its essence
outward
it doesn't win it back
that's a big problem
so hegel goes on and he says
um
it reverted to a consciousness for which
the object is something which merely is
a thing but here
what is a thing is self-consciousness
right this the thing is
self-consciousness why does he say that
because observing reason at the point
that we've arrived at the whole point of
doing the the physiognomy and the
phrenology and even the the portion
before it about logical and
psychological laws the whole point of
that was to make sense out of
self-consciousness reason wanted to know
what the hell is going on with human
beings how do they work how do they tick
and it treated them as things
over and over again
so he goes out and he says uh the thing
is self-consciousness therefore the
thing is therefore what does it mean to
be self-consciousness the unity
of i
and being
which is what here hegel uses this term
category
so we have over here the ich
all
right
why is hagel talking about category here
well he's talked about category already
in a fairly non-standard way earlier on
in this section in talking about
you know the individual making sense
of him or herself and also
in terms of agency right
but here
what we're looking at
is something that's supposed to be a
unity
of being in self and what is a category
supposed to allow us it allows a kind of
connection
a
a universality between the perceiver
and that which is perceived or that
which is acting upon
and willing and choosing
and that which is acted upon or willed
or chosen we can go on and on with this
right
so
don't read too many conscience overtones
into this at this point
hegel is going to go on and he says
now he's going to explore this notion of
the category says the object being
determined thus for consciousness
the latter consciousness possesses
reason
okay so all of this
possesses reason
right
he says consciousness as well as
self-consciousness is in itself reason
reason is the higher stage that we've
talked about so far
but only that consciousness for which
the object is determined as the category
can be said
to
have
reason
to have it in a sort of conscious way to
be
reasoning
about its own reasoning to be reasoning
about what it itself is
to be asking these fundamental questions
of what how do i work to have that
reflexivity that rational being
makes possible
so he goes on and he says from this
however we must still distinguish the
knowledge of what reason is
so the category which is again this
immediate unity of being self
must pass as he says through both forms
what does that mean so the category
has to be
essentially
divided
into the two forms i and being
and when we consider the side of being
the category is present as a being
so he says
here we go
is precisely for consciousness qua
observer the category presents itself in
the form of being
how do we have
being we don't have being without
consciousness
not consciousness in the being the
consciousness of the being
so we we still have a category that is a
unity between i and being but now on
this side as the the the being so he
says the consciousness in its result
announces as a proposition that of which
it is the unconscious certainty it
actually knows this at bottom the
proposition that's implicit in the
notion of reason this proposition
is the infinite judgment that the self
is a thing
now notice what he's going to say right
after that
a judgment that suspends itself
there's
to say that something is infinite
doesn't always mean that it's good
right there's a there's a bad infinity
of just oscillating back and forth or
just heaping up
extra stuff over and over again without
adding significance
so he says through this result the
category is further determined as being
this self-superseding antithesis the
pure category which is present
in the form of being or immediacy is the
object still unmediated
the self
being treated as a being
is not really grasped as the self you
might say
it's treated as merely given and
consciousness is equally unmediated in
its relation to it
so he says the the moment of infinite
judgment is the transition of the
immediacy into mediation
or negativity now where are we going to
get that well we have to swing over now
to the other side
where we find negativity
where we find negation going on
is in being for self
this sounds rather sartrin at this stage
i suppose to to some people who are used
to uh putting things in those terms but
this is where sartre got this sort of
stuff from right
so he goes on and he says
here we go
the the moment to that infinite judgment
the train okay the given object is
consequently determined as a negative
object consciousness
is determined as self-consciousness
over against it
in other words he says the category
which in the course of observation has
run through the form of being
is now posited in the form of being for
self
now here he's going to finally get to
the real meat the point of all this and
it's kind of ironic isn't it because
he's going to finish by talking about
something being its own point or end or
purpose it is itself the end at which
its action aims whereas in its role of
observer it was concerned only with
things right
we're seeing an enactment of exactly
what hegel's talking about here what is
all this about what is all this going
towards
this sentence
here
consciousness no longer
aims to find itself immediately
it's no longer
as it's trying to make sense of itself
trying to grasp itself
just in terms of being
like a skull
or its organs
it's got to be more than that
what's that more
some sort of vague spirituality a ghost
in the machine
no
what is it
activity
action
practice
doing
that is what consciousness
self-consciousness reason
is trying to grasp itself as he says
he says it no longer tries to find
itself immediately but to produce
itself
by its own activity
to produce itself
its action is no longer just an action
against other things or
uh
transforming other things
it is now explicitly engaged in
transforming or producing or finding or
doing
whatever we want to say here
itself
so observing reason having gone through
all of this having gone through this
entire
process of trying to you know figure out
things about the bumps on the head and
and you know looking at the the frame
all those sorts of things were leading
up to this point where it can finally
put that aside and say
that's interesting but it doesn't really
work what does work is figuring out what
i am by looking at what i do
how i do it why i do it and so hegel
finishes here by saying it is itself the
end at which its action aims its action
is not just to do things it's also to
understand itself
whereas in its role as observer it was
concerned only with things now it can
finally start to grasp itself
as spirit this is leading up to a
transformation in the notion of reason